how does one balance Family Life two
small businesses and a full-time job by
not judging themselves there is no such
thing as work life balance every family
is different there is no such thing
called balance you're the judge and the
jury just like a medium-sized business
or a small
business we do these things to make
ourselves upset we have to stop how do
you balance it by trying you try to go
to the recital you try to go to the
parent teacher conference you try to run
your business you try and if you try
your hardest and can't do it you should
not judge yourself what is can't what's
can't do it what does that even [__]
mean you missed a baseball game come on
the kids can have you miss a [__]
baseball
game if you are a good person and you're
trying truly trying and not trying to
hurt anybody you're [__]
phenomenal